[MUSIC]
We are now ready to learn how biologists
compare sequences.
And we'll start from something that, again,
seemingly has nothing to do with biology.
It's called the alignment game.
We are given two sequences, and we can do
the following things.
We can either remove the first symbols
from both sequences.
And in this case, if these two symbols
are the same, we get a score of one.
If they are different, we get nothing.
Alternatively, we can remove a single
symbol from one of the sequences.
Let's start.
So, this is how a sequence is and we got
lucky.
They both start from A.
We remove A from both sequences, and we
get one point.
Now, the sequences start from T,
once again, we remove both T, and we get
another point.
Next, the sequences start from G and C, so
we can either remove
both, but we'll get no point, or we can
remove one of them.
That's what we do.
And after we removed C from the second
sequence,
we actually have two sequences
starting from G.
That's good.
We can remove both and get one more point.
We continue,
one more point, continue, continue,
continue, and finally,
we finish doing the game, and got 4
points.
But maybe, if we played a different
strategy, we could get 5 points.
But before we decide how to play
this game.
Let's define the fundamental
bioinformatics notion of sequence
alignment.
We didn't notice it, but while we were
playing
the game, we actually constructed, the
alignment of two sequences.
Alignment of two sequences is a two-row
matrix.
In the first row, we have symbols from the
first
sequence in order.
Possibly interspaced by the space symbol.
In the second row, we have symbols from
the second sequence.
Once again in order, possibly interspaced
by the space symbol.
And that's what's shown on this slide.
They further classify different columns
of the alignment matrix as matches.
These are the columns for which we
get score one with identical letters.
Or mismatches, this is a column where we
have two letters but they are different.
And we also have insertions and deletions,
sometimes collectively called indels.
So, what we known is that the maximum
score in the alignment game is actually
the maximum number of matches,
is alignment matrix.
It doesn't help us, to solve either the
alignment problem or to play optimally the
alignment game.
But we will see later how to do this.
We will also define the notion of common
subsequence.
Common subsequence between two sequences
is simply the matches
in the alignment of these two sequences.
And a classical problem in Computer
Science
is called the longest common subsequence
problem.
Given two strings, we want to find a
longest common subsequence of two strings.
This problem will be the key for
our understanding of how biologists
compare by sequences.